what's up guys Sean here Sam is out
today but we got my friend Greg
Eisenberg filling in greg is a great
dude you guys will like him a lot
he's been a founder of a couple
companies sold two of them one to
stumble upon one to we work he's at we
work now he said investor in companies
he's a cool guy you guys would like him
a lot
he's got a real brain for designing
products anytime there's like a social
or consumer product he's one of the best
thinkers around and I think you guys
will see that we spent the first half of
the conversation talking a little bit
about his background and then the second
half case we go through a bunch of
random ideas he has on his you know
Notes app on his phone just for fun so I
think you guys will like it tweet at me
Sean VP tweeted Greg let us know what
you think about the episode as always
enjoy hope everybody's doing great out
there in the quarantine keep hustlin
building stuff keep yourself busy with
with good things all right take care
enjoy the episode okay so I should
introduce you so Greg is on the podcast
greg has a homie from I don't how long
over ninety few years at least we you
know I guess the world probably now
knows you for your haircut website right
explain what that is what is the URL do
you probably need a haircut
you probably need a haircut calm yeah
we're the the busiest virtual barber
shop on the internet dude so what
happened okay so people aren't
quarantine they need haircuts and how
does this idea go from a little germ a
little little sperm in your head to and
a real idea out there I mean you know me
I like you know I get sort of excited
about stuff that goes by Roe and I was
talking about buddy of mine he's a
stylist out of work couldn't pay his
rent I was like I need a haircut I like
to look good you know built the MVP and
then just threw it on product hunt and
before I knew it and when I was on The
Today Show ABC and basically the way it
works is pretty simple like for people
who need haircuts they book an
appointment they get connected to a
virtual stylist and they could either
cut their own hair or they can have a
friend cut cut their hair for you
this is a dope idea when it came out I
was like who's behind this I know I feel
like I know the person behind I don't
know is you when I was like I feel like
it see they do its Alex - all right it's
like you know one of you sort of viral
meemers of products yeah if you're like
actually generalize hours brainstorming
with you before I feel like for you to
get excited about building something
it's got to start with some emotion like
either you think of something that makes
you laugh and then you're just giggling
and but you're serious about it once you
start laughing or is something like
really sad story and you're like okay
this is an injustice in the world I
wanna go salt but is that a fair is that
a fair characterization of you yeah I
mean I do like things that kind of go
viral and like for me you probably need
a haircut I mean I was I told my
girlfriend I was like I'm a hundred
percent sure this is gonna go viral
and she's like well how do you know how
do you know and I was like well like the
name and and kind of you know where Brad
and it was the timing like you just seed
it with a couple of journalists and you
know throw it up on product hunt and
like before you know it like I don't
know we probably had 150,000 uniques in
the first 24 hours how many actual
haircuts probably more probably over a
thousand at this point yeah yeah
definitely more than we have one Silas
you did 200 so yeah more now any public
speaking thing where they like hey can
you send me like your bio this
absolutely needs to be the first thing
you know I you know conducted I'm
responsible for over a hundred thousand
haircuts and the crazy thing is that
people like actually look good like I've
I guys you don't have a haircut right
now you're growing it out they're crazy
try booking a haircut right like this
weekend if the site is busy now I'm an
entrepreneur I'm out here I gotta say I
got a make it happy bit of people I love
it there's a reason I have this hat on
because you know your boy butchered
himself with his own two a.m. haircut
keepers without using your website and
you can't declare so that's why all
right so let's give people background
and then we're gonna shoot the as
we do there hi Greg first do you
remember when you became a millionaire
do you remember the day of course you
always remember the day but I actually
like you know where I started actually
and I've never publicly said this word
where I started I think you might know
this where I started to actually make a
little bit of money was really as a
teenager doing affiliate marketing oh
absolutely
and like the underbelly of the Internet
yes and you know not people not a lot of
people talked about you know there's a
lot of actually great entrepreneurs who
who actually came from that area area I
think Julian Smith you know is also was
in that area as well but I actually
remember 2008 it was my I think was my
18th birthday and I was doing affiliate
marketing basically I was doing deals
with you know the eHarmony is the mash
comms that in and Zynga's who were like
they were willing to pay you three four
five six bucks for every install you
generated for them and back then there
was this Arbor I mean there's still
arbitrage now but there was this
arbitrage where if you could you know
create a landing page and cost you $1 to
to get someone to it to install that
game or get that lead to eHarmony they
would pay you five bucks right so I
would just figure out like kind of just
some innovative ways to do it you know
one one thing I did which you know which
I invented was the auto-playing video
pop-under ad which ruined the Internet
were you desperately trying to find
which tabs playing the sound well we did
it for a poker company and yeah that's
it and basically you know we I remember
getting like 1 2 % conversions on and
this is a pop-under ad to cut costs like
a fraction of a penny but you know from
that whole experience of like as a
teenager kind of working in affiliate
marketing it really just taught me like
what do people want yes because yeah you
know I didn't grow up poor or anything
but like my parents were giving me
to let go and a lot of money to let go
and buy the things that I wanted so I
was like okay I'm gonna have to go out
there and do it myself and I ended up
building you know I put it like okay a
hundred dollars a month on this landing
page a thousand and it sort of grew and
you really pay attention if it's your
own money you really do pay attention
and and you know if the difference
between like a one percent conversion
rate on one point two percent conversion
rate is if you make a hundred dollars a
day or lose a hundred dollars a day or
at bigger scales lose a hundred thousand
dollars a day or gain a hundred thousand
dollars a day and if you realize it's
it's around just subtle details like
having a woman with red hair or have the
eyes look at look at you in the landing
page or certain copy all these little
nuance things add up to the to getting
people to do things on the internet
totally me and I think you know fir
Conde the CTO had my startup we used to
literally look for hire for can we find
anyone who's done affiliate marketing
we're like the people who understand
those arbitrage they actually understand
how the internet works you understand
what makes people click what drives them
to actually take action how the
economics of the internet works how to
move traffic around and that's a problem
it's not a great long-term path but it
is like a great place to sharpen your
sword so that then you can do damage
with like products that actually matter
or like more sustainable businesses
versus these kind of like you know
moment in time arbitrage is yeah I was I
tweeted the other day actually I was
like the people I I want to hire are if
I'm building a consumer internet thing
is like X game developers or game
product people are game marketers or X
affiliate marketers like those are the
people that understand game dynamics
mechanics social mechanics how to how to
build like you know game game companies
have very sophisticated marketing
funnels and understand the flow very
well
and the same with affiliate marketers
like those are the people that have been
there done that better that are probably
undervalued in the market yeah and then
you you went on you did a bunch of other
things you did an agency yeah that was
kind of like building websites for big
big brand bigger brands yeah then you
decided we we
James Altucher on the last one he said
he did the same thing basically those
because kind of his first hit was like
making American Express calm or like
whatever those websites well yeah after
after I the affiliate marketing I mean
no one's lower on the totem pole in
terms of status and reputation and then
domain airs and affiliate marketers so I
was just like how do I gain credibility
so got into the agency game and said I
would only work with the top clients
which is all status all status like 100
percent says so did you have like status
symbols do you have like dope car or
anything like that did you do anything
to play the status game I mean not not I
mean I feel like for us like Internet
entrepreneurs like that's not even like
the status like the status isn't dope
cars or dope like houses I feel like
it's you know it's more about I don't
know um house invite or not yeah exactly
that's not you know it whatever is cool
at the moment so yeah I ended up start
you know doing this agency it was called
stress limit design we ended up doing
like high-profile projects like the
TechCrunch redesign which was like in
2010 which was like a big deal and that
spawned a lot of business and then like
I think you had Andrew Wilkinson from
tiny on the show we had a similar model
where we took a percentage of our
revenue and we built our own startups
and the startups is was all really all
around this idea around building mostly
communities so like we built like start
a vertical so we did like start cooking
calm which was like at the time the
largest video cooking set on the
internet things in the finance space a
company called Wall Street survivor
which became the most popular financial
education and stock market simulator on
the internet and just like how do you
look at a vertical and build something
that they really want and then wrap
around community yeah so did that and
then I realized I want to go do
something I want to do the whole San
Francisco kind of like I was living in
Montreal Canada at the time I'm like I
want to go do the whole like this is
like post social network right around
then probably when they came out of 20
2012 maybe and one day what did you
think was hot back then were you
like reading certain blogs was it too
the social network the movie what was
hot shake because I literally twenty
twelves when I moved to San Francisco -
and my journey was like I'm starting
like a restaurant I started I'm trying
to start the Chipotle of sushi at the
time which ended up becoming this like
Cod kitchen and then someone you know
mano mentor gave me the book the lean
startup and I was like oh yes we
should test if there's demand before we
pour everything into this inside
personal guarantees for this lease and
that led me to Paul Graham's essays and
I was like oh this guy this Paul Graham
guy this is the I don't know why
his website looks like this but this is
amazing and so then I started to like
you know drink the kool-aid of Silicon
Valley and I was just I picked up and
moved from Australia just off of the
kool-aid I changed my phone number I was
like here's a San Francisco phone number
that means I'm in I'm committed and then
I moved so what were you what got you
hooked I mean I'm like a product
designer so like for me I was really and
I love social apps and so for me it was
really like the Pat like Pat you know
that was like so cool back then you know
Pat yeah so yeah for those who don't
remember was like kind of a you know is
based on this idea around Dunbar's
number which is like a person only
really has 150 relationship so like what
if you designed a social network around
150 people like private and it was just
super well design and beautiful and they
invent they kind of were like way ahead
of their time like Danny Trin invent
like reactions and stuff like that right
and I just like remember looking at a
lot of like those people like the dig
guys the StumbleUpon guys and just being
like I mean you needed to be there you
needed to be there and then yeah you
know even if you took quick trips it
just didn't feel there was something
special going on in that era so came
down you're speaking past tense you
still think that's that's true or that's
not true anymore I mean I think it's for
me I think like Bay Area is like very
much I mean listen it's a wonderful
place but I think for most people it's
very much like I look at it like a
college experience like if you're not
from there it's like you go there for
six eight ten years you do your stand
them as much as possible you build your
network and then you bring it to
wherever you're from or whatever major
city that you live near absolutely
where do you live now no I live in New
York City now okay nice yeah
did you sell your place here or what
yeah it's gone you know I had this yeah
house here in San Francisco it was
awesome it was a great great little play
place I mean that was a crazy stay that
was like a commuted like it wasn't even
like it was my place but like it was a
community place okay
you know we threw so many events there
and it was you came to some and parking
space if instead of working you just
partied there it was like a co partying
space I do miss it so yeah I think like
you know that's what drew me to San
Francisco and I started something called
5by which basically took a look at all
you know integrated with all the video
popular you know apps like YouTube and
Vimeo and all these sort of sources and
we built like a beautiful curation layer
on top of it so that when you press the
funny button you'd actually get videos
that would make you laugh yep and we
sold that to stumble upon which is
Garrett camps company which at the time
was one of the largest social apps by
referring traffic so you ended up being
within reach of being able to invest in
uber right you know Garrett and then
what do you remember the first time you
heard that he was doing this thing yeah
I mean I don't remember exactly but I
remember when I met him you know
uber was you know it was a thing it
wasn't obviously what it is today but
yeah you know I definitely I definitely
wasn't like hey like take my money you
know I think but you know I guess you
live in you learn I have a friend who
you know Garrett pitched him and he was
in New York City you know one of the
smartest guys I know and Garrett pitched
him on the seed round of uber and and
this is in you know in Manhattan he was
just like Garrett like I don't know what
you're thinking about man like people
aren't gonna like press a button
like and like a car is gonna come it's
just you know you raise your hand look
at me I raised his hand watch this watch
this BAM you know like it's about
creating 10x better product this is in
10x quote-unquote yeah that's true in
New York it actually wasn't right this
isn't a whole bunch of other places it
was it's right it's like people without
with crypto they're like oh watch this
credit card boom paid for coffee I'm
done you know look at this Bank
you know don't need to worry about my
money it's like well yeah but that's not
the experience for most people in most
of the world and so maybe this doesn't
solve your problem but it's gonna solve
somebody's exactly so we don't crypto
guy my crypto guy I am I have some
crypto I not enough good to have some
crypto
I dabble I mean the my whole thing is
like everyone should have 2 to 5 percent
of their net worth in crypto as a hedge
right I calculated the other day I think
I'm at 9% because I was like am I going
a little too crazy with this like no no
it's okay it's at 9% that's that's
except it's in the acceptable range I'm
at 7.5% rows right so as it grows the
thing is are you gonna sell off no now
so yeah not not gonna not gonna sell off
Oh we'll see if this the exactly the
other thing is like pay to learn in a
way right like dude okay this is
interesting I need to get in the game I
need to get a little bit of skin in the
game just to like be be you know if not
like sort of driving things in that
space but at least I'm in the passenger
seat or the backseat or the trunk like
I'm involved in the journey of where
that's going by putting a little bit of
skin in the engine I highly recommend
that too because that's been my approach
with a lot of things now is just pay to
learn right yeah I think like for me
like I learn best when I'm just like
pushed into the ground just like push me
into the arena and like listen like I'm
like I've lost a lot of opportunity and
I've learned a lot of things and you
just have to assume that you're in it
for the long got long game and like life
is long hopefully and that you have
enough at it's all about at-bats like
getting at-bat trying different things
you know build good relationships in the
end you'll be
fine if you if you learn and if you have
a lot about that alright this episode is
brought to you by super side alright so
here's the deal I'm incredibly impatient
like horribly horribly impatient and if
I get an idea at midnight by 8 a.m. the
next day I want it done you know but
that's really hard because if something
needs to be designed where am I gonna
find a designer at midnight to try to
make this thing fit brain to life so you
know I don't lay I'm alone other
startups even huge companies need design
help fast and they just don't have the
internal resources or expertise to get
it done so how do you get reliable
design done without dealing with
expensive agencies and lots of
freelancers you used super side that's
our sponsor for this week just go to
super site calm slash MFM and tell them
what you want they have a team of
designers that can get it done fast you
know they are 20 times faster than
hiring a designer and 50% more
affordable than a traditional agency so
if you need high quality design done
fast try super side lots of fast growing
teams that are stretched or using them
already check them out super sicom slash
MFM I'm using before I love them check
it out so we sold the business to
stumble upon ran in as an independent
unit it sort of helped a somewhat upon
as well left I grew that to like one of
the fastest growing video discovery apps
at the time left in 2015 it and started
Islands which was based on this thesis
around group chat is the new social
network and it was gonna vertical eyes
and that you'd have a place to talk with
your workplace friends that became slack
a place to talk with your gamer friends
that became places like discord and we
focused on just the college market so
raised a couple million bucks on the
idea and away we went
and then now it's your story on how that
ended up so the story is we sold a
business to we work in May 2019
and I would have loved to have continued
building it out it you know it had
amazing I had a lot of really good
metrics like the daily active users
would send between 30 and 50 messages
every single day weekly active users
would open the
at 47 times per week the average user
would invite 2.1 people it was a
beautiful product people loved it so it
had like engagement it had written and
retention was a 50 percent 45 days so
like that's - you know it's like pretty
damn good for social app above above
what you'd normally see but like when I
went out in the market to raise money I
wanted to raise a lot of money and the
reason I want to raise it is because we
were seeing five to 25 percent
penetration and every school we launched
at within a couple of weeks and we had
all these metrics so it was just like
hey give us money so we can scale this
to every college the United States but
at the time this is around Facebook
antitrust type stuff Twitter wasn't
really like you know innovating that
much so they had a lot of like kind of
like health of the health and the
product that they were doing snapchat
the stock was at five dollars and ninety
cents like social was kind of like and
and house-party was flat you know so it
was kind of like no one wanted to look
at it you know and I could have raised
two three four million bucks to continue
it but like I was kind of like I'm very
much in you are to like very much like a
go big or go home yeah and I just
figured yeah let's find a good home for
ya okay gotcha all right so tell me tell
me what's it got your interest now so
what are you doing day-to-day basis
nowadays so I am the head of product
that we work which is awesome an
interesting place to be
I am a co-founder of a product studio
called late check-out it's spun up the
problem you need a haircut idea and
among other ideas which is kind of a
reincarnation of what we had it's stress
limit it's part agency part part
products to do I've been an advisor for
the last year and a half or two years
for tik-tok which has been amazing to
see because they've obviously grown
tremendously and
so I've been keeping busy yeah okay nice
so people when they listen to this but
they like to hear about is they like to
meet interesting people I think that's
check then the second part is the people
who are listening are your current
entrepreneurs in the market doing
something or they're people who have a
job or thinking about making the shift
or they're college student thinking
about making the leap and you know one
of the things that we do a lot of is we
sort of you know just in check or sort
of pontificate on you know why doesn't
somebody solve this problem or wouldn't
it be cool if you did this or hey that
things working what if you applied it in
this other way and so I'm curious do you
have I don't know do you have like and
your phone do you like a Notes app of
like startup ideas have big startup
ideas yeah I am probably there's
probably over a hundred ideas here I
thought what might be fun cuz you
mentioned that just before you're like
oh hey like you have any ideas I haven't
notes file I can literally just like
yeah let's do I can play we could play a
game where I just go like this and spin
the wheel yes let's do it
all right pulling it up okay some of
them are like you had a couple of
glasses of wine I understand I
understand all right
Metamucil for Millennials Metamucil does
what its rehydrating or it's like
diarrhea or whatever fiber fiber okay so
I think the genesis of this one was you
know I think I love subscription-based
businesses a lot of businesses that are
like repeatable um people who take
Metamucil take it every day mostly to
get their routine
yeah kind of in china routine yeah a lot
of brands right now are just being kind
of like rethought of with like obviously
is d2c with like kind of a nice brand
like I don't connect with Metamucil I'll
tell you about it all yes you know maybe
it just so it's like that's like a
no-brainer yeah I like that one
in fact wouldn't I did III did a podcast
with the guy from Seoul who created
Soylent and he was like yeah like you
know part of the original thesis was
kind of like the
you know what the other shake is called
ensure it's like ensure for Millennials
and right they don't they don't market
it that way but they were thinking about
it that way early on and so Metamucil is
another one all right I like it I'll
give that a solid matter than ten
actually I came out hot with that one
all right
spin again yes second opinion calm when
you need a second opinion on literally
anything okay it's giving you bends or
what I don't know man like being an
adult is hard right and we have to deal
with it and sometimes we need
relationship advice sometimes we need I
don't know how to fix something like you
know what I've learned from you probably
need a haircut it actually is that
people are actually open to getting help
and they'll pay for it right and so it's
like imagine you're having like a big
fight with your girlfriend and you want
to tell someone but you want an unbiased
opinion you need a second opinion based
on the text that you're gonna say right
second opinion calm here to help great
domain if you could get it okay I like
this what what vertical would be the
best that's kind of where this gets
interesting to me because I where would
you start and you know maybe you
actually just end there because it's
it's yeah you specialize but if nothing
else you start with one where people
really want this or people really have
this problem so so where could it we're
gonna be hot so a good framework for
thinking about like how to think about
consumer like Internet products is like
what is the thing that's gonna get a lot
of media attention because you want free
customers and you also yeah you want
free customers and also word of mouth is
the best customer anyways so like what's
something like why don't you just
reverse engineer what would be a good PR
story like that's just one way to look
at like MVP right it's like with the
minimal viable press release so somebody
was doing this like for dating profiles
which especially as tinder got hot that
was the time where somebody was like oh
my god there's tinder coaches they'll
give you a you know objective opinion on
your profile and how you're coming
across and right you pay for it and
that's like actually a thing and that
worked wait and that worked when there's
like kind of the way
Internet you know tinder itself was kind
of newsworthy you could piggyback off
that in the way that you guys sort of
piggyback to off of you know all the
sort of quarantine woes with the you
probably got a haircut so you'd probably
want to find something that is people
already talking about and then you sort
of you offer the second opinion around
that space exactly so you know maybe
yeah
so one idea is like maybe you start with
like relationship like relationship
advice because that's like my evergreen
that that's always and but then you've
launched like the viral piece of it
should I get a divorce calm or on top
you have to answer the why now and the
why now is like a lot of like single
people are like should I go on a date
with this person like an in-person date
less than six feet let's say or should I
make out with and then you press the
button and it's like no or something
like that
so we think like that's where it comes
down to like yeah like building little
games building a little like neurons
things that like surprise people delight
people people want to write about okay
love it spin again this is kind of like
I'm gonna give that one that's kind of a
penitent yeah this is maybe even a
three-and-a-half minute n but like
picking random ones here yeah text me a
secret calm and this is I didn't do a
full spin so I guess it was related to
second opinion calm but like we all have
secrets and a lot of time we want to
like talk about those you get them off
our chest get him off our chat chests so
this is a service that does that here's
another one like that idea so so here's
here's how what I'm imagining yeah I get
matched with someone and it tells me a
little bit about them
Johnny nine years old male San Francisco
rich and then he basically did but I but
I don't know more than that and then
they open up and you can open up or you
can sort of roulette wheel get to the
next person it's a secret network of
telling secrets to each other yeah man
is model is blackmail it's genius
we'll make millions I'm doing the money
burns
you know evil and next idea which is a
bit more the the opposite of this idea
more you know nice for the world is a
wash and fold for low-income families
so I a lot of people especially in New
York City but you know everywhere in the
world and cities spend a lot of time in
laundromats
and if you're a working mom or working
dad like you know sitting for 2-3 hours
of the laundromat is like take is a lot
of unproductive time that you could
either be spending with your children or
you could be like doing a side hustle or
whatever it is right so like how do you
like do wash and fold and just take that
out of the equation so that they can
focus on what it is they want to be
doing and so this just philanthropic
it's like it will be taken care of for
you we're gonna get back hours of
productivity to the people who people
who need it yes absolutely
ok here's right here's another one
Spotify but for work in progress it's
called watercolors so the whole idea
here is ok life is messy and there's a
reason why there is an eraser at the end
of a pencil but like when you go on
Spotify it's all these like highly
curated like I've produced this piece of
content for the last six years and this
is you know here - here it is right what
if whatever
what if artists can put like just like
little pieces of work that are like
unfinished and create almost like a
SoundCloud type website or app and and
it's called yeah what do I call it
watercolours I don't know why called the
watercolors but so for the unfinished
thing would it be like a dribble where
it's like a shot it's like it's like 10
seconds of the song it's not the whole
thing raw it's a snippet that you like
yeah it could be whatever whenever the
artist decides
so the artists decide they want to do a
like 10 second thing great this is like
here check this riff but I just think
that there's a whole dimension of music
that we're not exploring and I'd also
think that it's just kind of like I want
to see more apps I want to see more
websites where it's fine to put
unfinished work I think that's a part of
the creative process yeah and I think
that it's a good message that we should
be spreading yeah and I think stories is
an awesome format for unfinished things
like just like stories got people to
share little raw moments of their life
because they're like look it gets it's
gone after 24 hours I feel like if you
can make it ephemeral than more people
the question really is why don't people
share more unfinished work and then you
would work backwards from that like well
here's my objection here's my hesitation
here's what I'm worried about and then
you could figure out product design that
will solve those problems well yeah I
think like to talk to speak to that I
think you know artists and I include
myself as an artist because I'm a
product designer is like we don't we
we'd like to show our best work right so
like putting unfinished work isn't
quote-unquote our best work so I think
like a part of this is like ajik
that's a big challenge with this one but
I think like educating the artists
around like it's okay like you it's cool
like and in fact like if you're like an
artist hundreds of thousands of
followers or even like 20 like if you
just have like a thousand really engage
people like they want to interact like
III know there's one artist he has 2,000
followers but like he posts on stories
like little unfinished things and I'm
like post more of this right yeah I'm
with you
we I used to call it working in public
and then somebody sent me this link I
think Jessica Livingston or somebody was
calling it working with the garage door
open I don't know who it was reading but
they were saying like imagine your
startup you know you're starting in the
garage but what if you get the garage
door rolled open and like what are the
sort of serendipitous benefits you can
have of putting your work out there in
public mm-hmm another you want what you
want a couple more yes yes
I get we get literally do this for hours
this is just a concept so like I just
wrote you know what are cool ideas that
take something free and then you charge
for them like and then I put my G water
like water bottles if you think of water
bottles like no-one was charging for
water until something someone was like
hey wouldn't it be cool if like you can
transport this water and like food sell
it and then we could have like a luxury
brand like you can have Evian and it's
gonna be from France and then there's
this whole new category like new
categories the founder of Gumroad
tweeted the other day he was just like
do you want to make $10 an hour do you
see that tweet no I think you wanna you
want to make like $10 an hour like go
work for some someone you want to make
$100 an hour like charge companies or
something like that I'm butchering it
here but if you want to make a thousand
not like $1,000 an hour the point is it
was like you wanna make $10,000 an hour
creed create a new category and be like
the leader in the new category and I
think like I'm always interested in like
new categories like virtual Bert you
know barbershop new category like yeah
may not work but it might work and if it
works it's gonna work big uber new caddy
it's really just like a new on demand
like using technology to bring a car to
you like new category like boom yeah for
sure so what's something that's free
that could be it could be charged for so
for example water is a good example you
know when you first said that my brain
was like oh air but actually air is also
charged for air purifiers diffusers
things like that humidifiers there's pee
there's ways that people have found a
way to essentially charge for air in a
way their process processing it but
they're doing it what else is free that
could be charged for so content is I
mean the or put another way like
what are the things that we take for
granted as human beings that we can
charge for and that opens up like a
whole other set of products and services
and so forth because those are blind
spots right you have to actually think
hard because they are just embedded in
the world you
you don't even realize that they're
sticking out because there you take them
for granted by definition absolutely and
that's what I like I was before we were
chatting I actually someone called me
and was like Greg where do you where do
you see can't like the consumer Internet
going and I was like it's that this
stuff comes out of nowhere the stuff
literally comes out of nowhere there's
like you can look back in hindsight and
be like oh yeah like we can connect the
dots for these reasons but I think like
the dots are actually pretty messy to
connect if we actually look at it and I
think like the best actually consumer
businesses are kind of like somewhat
random there's someone random it's based
on like an entrepreneur just like being
obsessed with like like I been Ruben for
example the founder of house party he's
an architect he thinks of you know house
partiers is these rooms sort of physical
space you know digital representations
of these physical spaces the guy is like
spent years being you know studying to
be an architect and obsessing his like
entire teenage years about like presents
Ryan what that means so like it's not
because that in like 2016 or whatever
2015 like the live video was like
important why you know it was like no
the guys literally been like thinking
about it forever and he's like the
expert in the world on it have you ever
seen there's this video of Evan Spiegel
from snapchat he's in a kitchen and he's
explaining snapchat on like um you know
like a notebook they're just like a note
pad of paper and he's got like you know
he flips it three times and it's like
those are your slides essentially have
you seen this video I have it's actually
everyone should watch that
everybody should watch this video
because it's he's taking when you go
through that it's like I've never met
him but he's such a like you just
realized that he's amazing because he's
able to distill a really quote-unquote
complicated sort of like he just makes
it so simple and I think the beauty of
it is like everyone on this team could
look at that and like oh yeah then they
repeat it to other people yeah what
snapchat oh it's so hard to use no
actually it's so simple right exactly
yeah the video the video was amazing
even like I just never one detail in it
on the
design he's like yes so he explains
first you know why why you know it opens
up to the camera so you could take a
photo and it's meant to be
he's like basically photos today are
thought of as memories you take a photo
and you're stashing it away for
essentially your your keepsake he's like
but we use photos for communication we
just think if you send someone a photo
it's a great way to communicate you know
what you're doing how you're feeling if
you take a photo of your face it's you
know it's better than typing in many
ways like first snapchat is just using
photos and videos for communication not
for memories it's a boom insight one
insight he's like and then we created
this thing called stories and he's like
four stories you know what we wanted to
do is like every social network is
reverse chronological so you open up
your feed and you see sort of the latest
thing first music but that's not how our
brains are really wired you know we
communicate through story and that's
what we remember and so you know when
you click on a snapchat story it starts
from beginning then it goes middle and
end and it sounds like obviously duh but
that was counterintuitive Twitter was
reverse chronological Instagram was
reverse chronological Facebook was
reverse chronological your email was
reverse chronological and so that was
the you know with stories he's like when
do we do it beginning middle end you can
you know you're potent or when somebody
clicks your thing they're gonna
experience it the way you are wanting to
tell that story and I was like okay guys
a genius like that's what that is it's
taking complicated things making them
simple we're taking things that seem
simple on the surface and it's shot and
showing how much is actually below the
surface how much thought went into
crafting that simple experience yeah I
think what I like about that is like he
starts with the key insight well it's it
you know pictures worth a thousand words
is one way of looking at it so
communicating through photos is a richer
way of communicating through then
through text or calling somebody right
and so yeah great and people do do this
and that's sort of like the immediate
hater is well I can just I can go to
iMessage I can upload a photo and then I
can face right send and I can send that
to you and then sort of so the first
insight is people use photos for
memories they should use it for you know
it's really effective way to communicate
that's the insight and then he changed
the how which was like well
we reduce the friction to zero so like
you could open up iMessage click your
friends name click the camera button
click the gallery button find the photo
then hit Send and then they get it and
like then they view it or you open up
our app the cameras already open you
push you know you take the photo and
then you send it to as many friends as
you want one too many and like boom
that's done and so they change to how
lowered the friction of getting people
to do what they already wanted to do
alright so I think it starts with the it
starts with the key insight next it goes
to like what is who what is the
community that has a burning need for
this like instead of like a long you
know mistake a lot of people make is
they create software and then they find
the community versus like finding the
community and then building the software
right so like you know with this
particular key insight the way it
relates to the community I mean snapchat
started off in high schools in Los
Angeles had like preppy preppy preppy
country $50,000 year high schools and
these people were sending you know their
kids they're sending like naked pictures
they're sending pictures of drugs
they're sending things that their
parents don't want them to see or just
like making or just basically things if
their parents don't want to see so
election obviously should change one
think the unique insight wasn't just
that the user for communication it's
that wins photo stick around forever
people you know it's a hesitant to share
it sucks and so there's a whole bunch of
things we want to share that we don't
want to stick around forever and so that
ephemerality was the was sort of the key
mechanic so second second piece burning
you know what is the burning need for
the community and then third I think is
like okay how like what is okay now you
you want to build software now explain
to me how that ladders up to one and two
and why this is the most beautiful and
the fastest and you know and then if you
have those three like forget Dex forget
like business plans like just show me
one two and three and if you show me one
two and three two and three like the
market for you know when people looked
at uber and them initially people like
on-demand black cars San Francisco come
on
right such a small market what are you
talking about it I know I know people
who've done who did that and it's like
yeah like but sometimes small markets
you can't always pick a really big
market sometime so small markets
actually expand to be new categories in
really big markets so I think you got to
play the field I think you got Austin
you got to look at small you got to look
at medium and look at large and I don't
think that if the market is small you
should be like I can't do this right and
I guess if we're being honest with
snapchat they didn't realize the high
school was the community that they that
would need this the most because I think
what ended up happening was they had it
they built it while they're in school
summer hit usage was pretty flat they
were thinking like Oh college kids will
want to do this which ended up being
true college kids did want to use it to
send photos from parties and whatnot
photos you don't want to stick around
forever and then somebody you know to
introduce it to their knees or something
that something like that and they
basically not in the school I think they
were using it it was am i right on iPads
to send sort of in classroom iPads to
send you know messages to each other
across classrooms or whatever and the
teachers couldn't catch it basically
because the message destroyed Burn After
Reading essentially is that it they do I
have history correct yeah that's it
that's it and then with uber same thing
where I think they also probably thought
it was a small market because neither
Garrett nor Travis ran the company
initially right they hired a guy they
you know guy off Twitter wants to run
this yes sure come on over and he became
a billionaire you know but like I think
if they knew whatever becomes they
probably run it from day one themselves
I think they sort of observed over time
holy there's a lot of poll here and
then this could go even further and so
you know it progressively stacked up
from there I agree and I think like for
for the people listening I think it's
important to like when you're thinking
about what do you want to spend your
time doing think about like what have
you spent your time doing like what have
you spent your life doing and why why do
you have like this unique advantage or
these you know what are some key
insights that you can have about the
world that that you could so what was
the answer for you for I mean I have a
law I had you know I think every person
has had unique insights like for example
like or unique backgrounds like my my
family
used to own like store you know stores
in Quebec for I don't know 100 years and
I grew and because of that like every
Saturday my mom would drop me off at the
mall where my dad's store was and I
spent a lot of time in the mall frankly
because that's my mom was there my dad
was there and my dad was working so I
kind of like walked around I got to know
them all really well and I've learned I
have a unique perspective on the world
in terms of like Commerce in terms of
like what is the mall even represent as
like a meeting point for people to like
you know young people and old people and
why are they there and like what what
are the types of restaurants there why
is there a restaurant why is the food
court here like why are things you know
how are things merchandise you know I
think one of the big reasons I became a
product designer was because I saw that
you know if you put like a product by
like I remember like yeah basically like
if you put products like near you know
the lineup like people will buy them and
I was like wow like the ui/ux you know
the interface and user experience of the
physical world is a real thing and that
just led me to digital right yeah for
sure so I like that basically there's
one one school of thought and I think
this is a Paul Graham school of thought
is where I sit this idea from but
he basically says if you want to invent
the future just live in the future and
then invent what's missing and it's not
sort of this crazy thing it's like back
to this there's some quote but it's like
if you want to paint the perfect
painting become perfect and then just
paint my idea is like if you already do
something in your lifestyle that is
unusual that is sort of forward-thinking
in some way maybe you're somebody who
doesn't own your house you you rent any
rent your car and you rent everything
then the sharing economy is quite
obvious to you right if you go and do
couchsurfing and you think that's normal
Airbnb is normal is a normal idea for
you even though it's abnormal to others
but to you you're like no I live in this
future where this is true right I push
button and my groceries appear not
everybody does that today but I live in
that future where that that exists and
I'm going to sort of enable that for
more people all right and so one way of
looking at it is what
one of the things that are normal to you
it's normal to me to record something
and have hundreds of thousands of people
I've never met
listen to me in their ear balls every
morning while they commute to work and
they feel like they know me that's a
normal thing for me but not for most but
like maybe there's something that I
could sort of make that make that make
my normal normal for others so that's
one way think about it and when you said
it sort of the the the counter to that
or the compliment to that which is you
know don't try to get interested in sort
of new things to try to create a company
look at what you're already interested
in the life you've already lived and
there's embedded insights and domain
expertise and nuance that you understand
because you lived that way and then
think how do i how do I start something
that leverages those insights and that
experience that I've already had yeah
and and be mindful of the fact like oh
hey like why why am I so why do I love
this P like why do I love spending time
at the mall or like why do I love
looking at like how things are
merchandise and stuff like that Wow like
I I have an eye for that and let your
imagination go wild and be like oh you
know it would be cool if you could do
this you know like what if you could do
that and then then that's when you start
like oh yeah wouldn't it be cool if you
can like create that something and
that's when a business is created to
fill that void what are some of the most
interesting either products or startups
you've seen invested in do notice
existing things what are some of the
most interesting things that have caught
your eye lately so I'm sure like pull up
my phone
there's an app have you I was playing
with it today it's all it's me do you
know it's me no this is a yes okay I
think I have but I forgot what it is
yeah so it started it recently started
to kind of take off but the way it works
is you login with snapchat it pulls your
bitmoji and you see your age if you want
to meet with like girls or guys or both
and it chatroulette style like you press
a button it connects you to someone it
so it says a bit about
like where they're from who they are and
you see you're at the Avatar talk so
like you're like you're you're talking
but you see yourself as an avatar yep
and I think when I find you know like
what is the key insight there is that
like then like being you know if for a
lot of people like being in a physical
form be it even on like a zoom or face
time or you know literally physical is
tough for people yeah and having that
like wall is nice as like an icebreaker
to eventually get you to meet in person
etc I like that let me connect that to
the last idea so when I first started
working in this kind of twitch ecosystem
to live Khmer ecosystem I saw this get
one guy his name's Manny
I think his handles like the one Manny
or something like that
and Manny it streams on Twitch but he's
a dog he's not actually a dog he's a guy
but his avatar is a dog and so he's one
of the few twitch people who their
little webcam areas not themselves it's
a it's a dog that he uses this you know
obscure app or a cup I think I might've
got bought by now but it's called face
rig at the time so face rig was this
obscure app you have to have a Windows
machine go on Steam download face rec
pay 20 bucks for face rig then you get
the dog and the dog will mimic your head
movements and your mouth movements while
you're streaming and so for him he was
like oh yeah this is way more
comfortable for me than putting my own
real face out there as the like kind of
the show and and so I saw that and then
I tried it and I was like wow that
really does make me feel way less
anxious about kind of like performing if
I if I just have this little you know
goofy looking dog as me instead of me
and so that's another one where it's
like okay it took today it took a lot of
extra work yet to go find this app
download it pay money blah blah blah set
it up on a PC book but once you've
experienced the magic at the end of that
you're like okay magic is here now can I
make this way less friction I've lived
in the future I take I saw what life is
like and now I'm gonna bring that back
to the present and make it accessible to
more people and it sounds like these
guys were guys and gals were building
this app might have done that they might
have made it way simpler for somebody to
have that same experience yeah
absolutely and it's simple it's fast and
magical and I think what I'd like about
it I like about your story actually is
that like that dude was like he was
unique and he was like yeah I'm gonna do
this I don't care what people think like
this is what I'm gonna do and he like
pushed the envelope and did something
weird and it turns out like weird things
are actually like head-turners I had
like head-turners are actually create
word of mouth and word of mouth actually
creates audience and creates buzz and
creates all these things so like same
with snapchat right like that and it's
obvious now that like a message would
disappear a photo would disappear a
video would disappear but at the time
like no one that didn't exist it's a new
concept so like people like you know
listeners like tap into that like
uniqueness about yourself and don't be
afraid to do it because who knows you
might be on the verge of a snapchat or
anything like that
and people will doubt it there's a
reason my snapchat handle is still SVP
test because I was like this happened
going nowhere right like I don't to
worry about making a real handle here
I'll just do this test account because I
just want to try this silly fad and then
you know this will be gone in a month
and of course famous last words
yeah absolutely let me give you let me
give you an idea that's sort of like
that okay so my friend Damien he's the
founder of a company called doodle have
you ever heard this I haven't it's like
a British based company due diligent due
diligence so basically they surface
private company information in a way
that's I think the EU has different laws
of what you need to disclose so he can
provide like you know revenue
information employee information so you
can get a lot more information about
companies there so he built this
platform it's like fin tech guys doing
fin tech things it's a super group at
the super valuable company I think it
might be a billion dollar company and
anyways he did that and so the other day
I see him on Facebook any posts like hey
you know you know I you know I've left
and I was thinking about my next thing
so I come up with this new thing called
Battelle and I was like oh what's
Patel is this like some neo bank
is this well you know what is this new
FinTech product he's like it's not
FinTech it's a remote sleep school for
parents and basically he's like I met
this woman and what she does is she
teaches parents how to put their baby to
sleep and you know so they get a good
night's sleep and the parents aren't up
all night feeding every two hours and
whatnot and she doesn't use what's
called the crying out method which is
the normal way you do this but it's like
really hard on the parents to fight
through and let their kid cry it out
she's like she doesn't use the cried out
method and she's a you know she's like
the dog whisperer it's amazing I watched
her work her magic on two hundred
families and I thought okay I'm gonna
help this woman scale her her you know
magic too you know as many families as I
can and so he created this remote sleep
school it's basically cost a thousand
bucks but you're gonna teach your kids
gonna get a good sleeping program so
it's like you know what's that worth to
you and like I don't got enough to know
this I had a kid eight months ago so now
I'm in that position and so I was like
oh dude I'll beta test this now because
you know I'm going on three hours of
sleep right now and damn I would love if
I could you know do this and so I think
that there's these fringe sort of weird
things where it's like what people
really pay a thousand dollars for this
woman to zoom call you and and teach you
how to put your kid to sleep like you
know but I think that that's one of
these products that is just weird enough
solves a real problem and like adds a
lot of real value in his chart is
charging for something that normally
this advice is just like a free mommy
blog telling you hey try this and
instead it's like no here's a super high
end version of that but we're gonna
guarantee the result in in a better way
than the average blog would do what do
you think of that idea
I think it's actually really like it I
think like I'm a big believer in you
know come for the tool stay for the
network I like the way I look at it is
like come for the tool stay for the
vertical network where the vertical here
would be parents yes like the fact that
he's capturing such a high like you're
just in the beginning stage is my friend
and like you're you're about to buy a
whole lot of products and services for
your child and maybe even more children
if you have
so like the fact that like here's the
thing here's one thing I'll tell you if
if they help you with this problem
you're definitely gonna be wow that was
amazing so bottom will be like 1,000
points you know right so that's what it
is it's like when you're looking at like
building a vertical something in a
vertical it's all about like what is the
trust quotient you can have with the
vertical and I like that this particular
task will give you a lot of a lot of you
know a lot of cred for this business
yeah man I think like that's the other
thing is like it could I could see it
being like a million dollar a year
business but I can also somehow see it
being a billion dollar right business
and so it's worth a shot
yeah you know the math I think works
where he has both options where it's
like you know thousand people paying a
thousand bucks a month or sorry thousand
bucks for the program that's a million
bucks and can he find a thousand parents
to do this I'm very confident just
through Facebook ad so I think he could
bootstrap two million dollars in revenue
very quickly with sort of like 30 40
percent margins on that and and just
pocket that so I think very low-tech
easy to start bootstrap a bull into the
single-digit millions let's call it
between one and nine million or what you
said which is like cool if he thinks
about this bigger like how do I now that
I have trust with these parents and I've
solved one problem for them the problem
they had during their first seven months
of their baby how do I help them with
their next phase in the next phase in
the next phase and you know could go
good go bigger from there so I like I
like having those options on the table
where it starts with sort of those
humble beginnings and it might just be a
great cash flow business or goes for the
sort of home run yeah man
tell them to keep going well well I
don't think you I don't think it is my
my encouragement to keep going that's
the best entrepreneurs donate any advice
I invested in this resident lamb to
school and afterwards I was talking my
friend we get it together and I was like
here's three reasons you know here's
what I want out of this investment I
don't know if this will make us money or
not but you know I want to learn about
like this idea of this trade school
thing for education I want to hang out
with the founder you know monthly and be
helping
problems I think will be really
interesting and you know lastly I hope
we get a return on this he replied he
was like all I care about is the return
don't give a about the rest but hey
to each of their own and on my end I was
like and ironically the return is gonna
be there but for the first - like Austin
doesn't need my help doesn't ask for my
help you know if I text him something
I'm actually just taking up his time and
it reminds me of kind of what an
investor told me which is the best
companies don't need us that's the
reality of the value add services is
that the best companies rarely need your
help and the worst companies you can't
save anyways and so there's some in the
middle where you can help influence
their trajectory but this idea of
investors really helping out or
encouraging entrepreneurs or whatever
else is sort of overblown marketing I
totally agreed I think I actually last
week there's a spanner he's just like
literally crap he crushes it like for
years he's done ten percent
year-over-year growth and I started
month over month growth and I responded
to his investor update keep it up and
then he just responds right away he's
like as if I wasn't going to keep it up
[Laughter]
I picture myself smiling and sent it
back then that's so good it's great
alright we should wrap up kind of weight
over time but yeah anything else we do
one last spin of the one last bit of the
idea well let's do these get one more
than we're out of here throw it notes
boom okay so this one is a quarantine H
idea but it could last beyond quarantine
it's an idea that basically I called it
chef's table
and it's this idea that like I don't
know if you saw a car bone then the
restaurant in New York City is not doing
they're just doing one meal per night
and then it sells out so it's kind of
like a drop yeah
which builds a lot of buzz and demand
and it sells out and every night this
idea is that like it's it's it's a drop
for
strong but you have a live stream with
the chef telling you about like if it
comes with wine or or the meal it's like
this is how I did it and it's more of an
experience live stream is after you
order order
so everyone the way would work is you
would you would order it everyone which
is everyone would get the meal at the
same time I don't care if you want and
then chef comes and he's like listen
like I you know pick these these you
know carrots myself and Hudson Valley
and here is explaining it and I think
like that's what I miss most about sort
of restaurants I guess is like the the
stories behind right and then this the
experience behind it which you don't
really get if you're just like frying up
some eggs in the morning for sure okay
so here's a twist on this idea you're a
high-end restaurant your business is
gone right now like you're a Michelin
star restaurant what do you what are you
doing you can't do anything and so
here's your your pivot you go live on
Instagram before the drop so you live
before and you're showing the prep it's
the you know you're in the chef's
kitchen they're talking about it they're
drinking wine there and you're seeing it
being prepared and people I think like
to see as the show chef's table is shown
people like to watch high-end food get
made a real skill you know that that
sort of thing as long as you have a
personality with it and and then
basically by the end of the 20 minutes
the the meal is ready for the drop the
drop goes live and it's you know it uses
the new Facebook shop thing that came
out yesterday you'll push the button and
it orders it basically and it is like a
hundred dollar meal and it's you know
it's the stuff you don't find on post
mates or GrubHub or whatever which are
all kind of like the bottom of the
barrel so you come in at the very top
end of those and it's like the delivery
experience is gonna be you know the
packaging is gonna be amazing and
whatnot but you're gonna get what you
just saw on the IG live and so you do
these like 100 or $150 drops you know
I'm for high-end stuff through the
through the delivery network but you go
live before
to build up that that anticipation of
QVC but for high-end cooking I like it I
think we kind of merge the ideas that's
right it's nice to have co-founders okay
great I'll incorporate it and we'll get
this off the ground so we all right
great where should people find you if
they like your your style they want to
hear more of you if you want to hear
more of me check me out on Twitter my
name's at Greg Eisenberg GRE G is e and
B ERG check then just holler cool we'll
put it in the show notes - all right all
right well I got a run but there's been
yeah good catching up yeah you too take
care I'm at sea
[Music]